a few months ago you may have seen
something called night of too many stars
on HBO it was this giant comedy benefit
that was raising money for autism
programs which is obviously a terrific
cause we're very excited about that and
so during the benefit a lot of
celebrities donated one-of-a-kind
experiences that people can enter to win
to help raise money for this excellent
cause so they asked us what we would
offer and we offered one lucky person
the chance to co-host our show for a
night okay and ladies and gentlemen the
winner is here with us this evening
please welcome a very charitable
gentleman my co co host for the evening
mr. Andy Ross let's get him out here
[Applause]
[Music]
thanks for being here readings Andy and
also thank you very much for donating to
this great cause well thank you Conan
for supporting it and having me here
yeah yeah lovely and the nice thing
about him is he brought his own podium
when he came that was he's apparently
wanted his cake for her really long time
it's how it's from the Andy Richter
collection you see it's a collection
it's a cheap knockoff but it's sort of
the same this is much nicer yeah okay
you know I living Andy we talk remember
I'm kidding ad-lib all you want we are
thrilled that you're here tell us what
it is what is is you do for a living I'm
a lawyer you're a lawyer yes okay you
can go now where are you from Andy New
York City New York City what part of New
York City the Upper West Side I lived
there for many years you ever see me
walking around the neighborhood I think
so yeah so it's not you running around
there yeah it was
you got the right guy you know me always
running around what do you what do you
think and he's he got the chops no it's
great I'll have something to talk to
while you're doing those jokes meanwhile
you're busy laughing so hard at my joke
oh right right right that's what I mean
dude do you know what's a lawyer I told
him that when I tell jokes he's really
got a laugh like they're funny no no
let's hear your boy Conan's fighting
tonight laughs can you give it to us
[Laughter]
Andy Andy Richter I don't know about you
but I find it a little chilling that
Andy steps away in pain he laughs it
sounded a little evil it sounded a
little evil like he's evil person I'm
told Andy Ross I have to say your last
name because we got to Andy's here it's
very disconcerting I'm told that you
have kind of a funny anecdote about
something it happened to you while you
were in China you sometimes go to China
and do business there yes we didn't tell
us what happened I've been there a
number of times and the number of times
Chinese women have come up to me and
asked me if I'm Richard Gere you know
wait a minute okay well hold on you seem
skeptical but let's put up a
split-screen cuz there maybe is gonna be
some let's put up a split-screen here
[Applause]
please and turnin Chinese women agree
[Applause]
that's amazing so but this really has
happened to you right you've been in
China and and absolutely women come up
to you and in fact this happens so often
is it not true that you become a little
bit of a celebrity in China a little bit
a little bit yeah I'm told you say a
little bit he's a modest fellow
I'm told that auntie Ross here shot an
ad that currently airs in China is that
true yes it is yes it is all right
ladies gentlemen we got a hold of it
take a look Neha I'm Andy Ross a New
York City Attorney but when I'm in China
I'm a Hollywood actor Richard Gere when
you're a special kind of woman do you
need a special kind of Bath Project
that's why I recommend pretty woman
brand bubble baths for prostitutes it's
the world's oldest bubble bath just like
the kind Julia Roberts's take it for me
China is Richard Gere you don't have to
be a prostitute to use it but it helps
[Music]
my daughter penny feeling
freak nicely done I like that little
creepy twist at the end
you